Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Hello and welcome to The Rest Is History with me, Dominic Sandbroek, and my friend Tom Holland. Hello. We've come to the subject of Holland, the Netherlands. Yeah, we're going to do the whole thing in Dutch accents and everybody will find that enormously amusing.
感谢收听《历史余音》。想要每周收听独家加更节目、无广告音频、抢先体验系列节目并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区吗？请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。大家好，欢迎收听《历史余音》，我是多米尼克·桑德布鲁克，和我一起的还有我的朋友汤姆·霍兰。大家好。我们今天的主题是关于霍兰，也就是荷兰。对，我们要全程用荷兰口音来聊，大家一定会觉得超级搞笑。
So anyway, yes, Tom, you are very keen on the Netherlands, not merely because you're called Holland, I think, but because you genuinely... Yeah, that's part of it. You like the history, don't you, of the Dutch Republic? I do, I do. And actually, the book that got me interested in it, I'm sure like so many people,
所以总之，是的，汤姆，你对荷兰非常感兴趣，不仅是因为你姓霍兰，我想，还因为你是真心……对，这也是原因之一。你很喜欢荷兰共和国的历史，对吧？是的，是的。实际上，让我对它产生兴趣的那本书，我相信和许多人一样，
is Simon Sharma's The Embarrassment of Riches, which was his first great book came out late 80s i think i read it at university yeah a brilliant portrait of the dutch republic in its golden age and i've read and reread it and i always remember there's a particular sequence about the the significance of housework to the dutch in their golden age such a glamorous subject tom it. It is a glamorous. Well, it's a very, very interesting subject, I think. I know that you disagree about this, don't you?
就是西蒙·沙玛的《财富的尴尬》，这是他的第一本伟大著作，出版于80年代末吧，我上大学时读的。是的，这是一幅荷兰共和国黄金时代的绝妙画卷，我读了又读。我一直记得其中有一个特别的片段，讲的是家务劳动对黄金时代荷兰人的重要性。多么迷人的主题啊，汤姆。这确实很迷人。嗯，我认为这是一个非常非常有趣的主题。我知道你对此有不同看法，对吧？
You're sceptical. But the subject of today's Dutch-themed episode is the Maid of Holland, the Hollandsche Macht. I hope that my translation there was right. And the Maid of Holland emerges in the late 16th century as basically the most potent symbol of the Dutch Republic. And so I thought it would be interesting to ask, you know, who is she? Why? What are the symbolic resonances? And I know you're skeptical, but I'm going to try and convince you that this is actually a fascinating topic. To start with, explain. So we are in what, the 17th century? No, we are a little bit earlier. We're in the late 16th century. This is the Dutch revolt against the Spanish.
你对此持怀疑态度。但今天这期以荷兰为主题的节目的主角是“荷兰少女”（the Maid of Holland），即“荷兰权力”（the Hollandsche Macht）。希望我刚才的翻译没错。“荷兰少女”在16世纪后期崛起，基本上成为了荷兰共和国最具影响力的象征。所以我想，探讨一下“她是谁？为什么？有哪些象征意义？”会很有趣。我知道你持怀疑态度，但我会试着说服你，这其实是一个引人入胜的话题。首先，解释一下。我们现在是在什么时候，17世纪吗？不，我们要再早一点。我们在16世纪末。这是荷兰人反抗西班牙的起义。
Yeah. And this is the kind of the northern part of the lowlands. People remember that episode we did on Burgundy with Bart van Leeuw, that these cities, these kind of city-states, which today would embrace the Netherlands and Belgium, we did on Burgundy with Bart van Leeuw, that these cities, these kind of city-states, which today would embrace the Netherlands and Belgium, that they had their golden age under the Dukes of Burgundy. They then become part of the Habsburg inheritance. And so in the 1560s, the northern part of the Netherlands, what will become the Dutch Republic, is becoming ever more Protestant and specifically Calvinist.
对。这是低地国家北部的一种情况。大家还记得我们和巴特·范·莱乌一起做的那期关于勃艮第的节目吗？这些城市，这些城邦——今天包括荷兰和比利时——它们在勃艮第公爵统治时期迎来了黄金时代。它们后来成为了哈布斯堡王朝遗产的一部分。所以在16世纪60年代，荷兰北部，也就是后来的荷兰共和国，变得越来越新教化，特别是加尔文主义化。
And therefore, that gives a religious dimension to the resentment that they feel about their distant Spanish overlord, Philip II. And from the mid-1560s onward, you get this process of kind of revolt and rebellion until in 1588, the Dutch Republic is officially proclaimed. And English listeners, of course, 1588 is the year of the Spanish Armada. And people remember that the whole point of the Spanish Armada is that it's going to sail up to the lowlands and take on the Spanish armies that are there. And the reason that there are Spanish armies in the lowlands is because they are busy fighting the rebellious Dutch. And 15 years before the official proclamation of the Dutch Republic, the rebels had issued a medal that had the two words libertas, so freedom and patria, fatherland, motherland, stamped on it. And the emblem on this medal was a maiden wearing a hat, seated within a garden with a fence around it.
因此，这就为他们对远在天边的西班牙最高统治者菲利普二世的不满增添了宗教维度。从16世纪60年代中期开始，你就会看到这种反抗和叛乱的过程，直到1588年，荷兰共和国正式宣告成立。当然，对于英国听众来说，1588年是西班牙无敌舰队之年。人们记得，西班牙无敌舰队的全部意义在于它将驶向低地国家，迎战那里的西班牙军队。低地国家之所以有西班牙军队，是因为他们正忙于镇压叛乱的荷兰人。而在荷兰共和国正式宣布成立的1588年之前的15年，叛军就发行了一枚奖章，上面印着两个词：libertas（即自由）和patria（祖国、母国）。这枚奖章上的徽标是一个戴着帽子的少女，坐落在一个四周有栅栏的花园里。
And this maiden is Hollandia. It was a figure from medieval allegory in the Middle Ages. Every city, every town, every region would be represented by an allegorical female figure. So that's where she's coming from. But on this medal, she's freighted with all kinds of extra symbolism and moral weight. So there are obviously, it won't surprise you to hear from me, Dominic, there are very strong Christian echoes here. And specifically of the Virgin Mary. So this is a Protestant revolt. So the kind of the Mariolatry of the Middle Ages is something that's been parked by the Dutch
这个少女就是“霍兰迪亚”（Hollandia）。她是中世纪寓言中的一个人物。在中世纪，每一个城市、每一个城镇、每一个地区都会由一个寓言式的女性形象来代表。这就是她的由来。但在这枚奖章上，她被赋予了各种各样的额外象征意义和道德分量。所以很显然，多米尼克，你听了可能不会感到惊讶，这里有着非常强烈基督教回响。特别是圣母玛利亚的痕迹。所以这是一场新教起义。因此，荷兰
rebels. But you don't suppress the memory of something as potent as the imagery of the Virgin overnight. So just as in England, Elizabeth I becomes Gloriana, she kind of takes on a lot of the allure and the glamour and the symbolic potency of the Virgin Mary, becomes a kind of Protestant equivalent of the Virgin Mary. So with this medal, this image of the maid of Holland, the idea of the garden that can't be broken into in the Middle Ages, this serves as an emblem of Mary's virginity. And so at a time when the Dutch rebels are trying to create a kind of impregnable border between them and the Spanish armies. And also, of course, because their towns and their fields have been redeemed from the North Sea by dykes.
叛军将中世纪那种对圣母玛利亚的崇拜暂时搁置了一旁。但是，你无法在一夜之间抹去像圣母玛利亚意象这样具有强大力量的记忆。就像在英国，伊丽莎白一世变成了“荣耀安娜”（Gloriana），她承载了圣母玛利亚许多的魅力、风采和象征力量，成为了圣母玛利亚的一种新教替代品。因此，通过这枚奖章，“荷兰少女”的形象、中世纪那种无法被攻破的花园的概念，成为了圣母贞洁的象征。当时，荷兰叛军正试图在他们和西班牙军队之间建立一条坚不可摧的边界。此外，当然也是因为他们的城镇和田野是通过堤坝从北海中夺回的。
The idea of a kind of unbreachable wall is very, uh in in the early years of the dutch revolt is that as they they you know it's kind of iconoclastic approach to um churches and cathedrals and stained glass window will be destroyed when they repair them often the maid of holland replaces the virgin in the iconography of these stained glass windows that's interesting yeah thank you dominic thank you so it is interesting that's i'm chalking that up as a victory so there's there's that kind of christian That's interesting. Yeah. Fridgen hats. The hat that the maid is wearing is a more typical hat, but it's still serving as an image of liberty. And in due course, actually, the rebels will start minting medals that just show the hat. So the hat becomes a kind of, you know, a totem of Dutch liberty. But of course, the other very, very very celebrated symbolically freighted uh virgin
这种坚不可摧的墙壁的概念非常……在荷兰起义的早期，当他们采取一种类似圣像破坏的方式来对待教堂、大教堂和彩绘玻璃窗时，这些都会被摧毁。当他们修复这些窗户时，“荷兰少女”往往会取代彩绘玻璃图像中的圣母。这很有趣。是的，谢谢你，多米尼克，谢谢。所以这很有趣，我把这记为一次胜利。所以有那种基督教的色彩。这很有趣。弗里吉亚帽。少女戴着的帽子更像是一顶普通的帽子，但它仍然作为自由的象征。随后，实际上，叛军开始铸造只印有这顶帽子的奖章。因此，这顶帽子变成了一种荷兰自由的图腾。当然，另一个非常非常著名、充满象征意义的少女
female virgin is minerva athena the goddess of wisdom who is also a warrior yeah famous for her helmet famous for her helmet yeah yes absolutely um and the idea of the maid of holland as a kind of athena figure a minerva figure enables the the uh the people who are kind of Athena figure, a Minerva figure, enables the people who are kind of manufacturing this image to allude to real life examples of women who display their heroism and their virtue by defying the Spanish. And there's one person in particular who is a kind of absolute totem of Dutch heroism, who's a woman in Harlem. She's a wood merchant by the name of Kenau Simons Dochter Hasseler. Very good.
处女是雅典娜（Minerva），也就是智慧女神，同时她也是一位女战士。对，以她的头盔闻名，以她的头盔闻名。是的，绝对是。而且，“荷兰少女”作为一种雅典娜式、密涅瓦式的人物形象，使得那些制造这种形象的人能够借此影射现实生活中那些通过蔑视西班牙来展现其英雄主义和美德的女性。其中有一个人特别引人注目，她可以说是荷兰英雄主义的绝对图腾，她是哈勒姆的一位女性。她是一名木材商人，名叫基瑙·西蒙斯多赫特·哈瑟拉尔（Kenau Simonsdochter Hasseler）。很好。
If I've pronounced that right. Superb. And in 1573, the Spanish have put Harlem under siege. They've destroyed the walls. And again, you know, again and again, the significance of walls, of dikes, of barriers, so important to the Dutch rebels. And so the people of Harlem,
如果我没发错音的话。太棒了。在1573年，西班牙人对哈勒姆进行了围攻。他们摧毁了城墙。再次强调，墙壁、堤坝和屏障的重要性，这对荷兰叛军来说是一次又一次地被提及，至关重要。所以哈勒姆的人民
they work tirelessly night and day to try and repair the breaches. And Kenau is the woman who becomes the emblem of this repair work. She never stops. She's absolutely indefatigable. And over the course of the years and then the decades that follow, stories told about her become ever kind of more implausible. So it's said that she basically she develops the necklace. You remember the necklace in South Africa? It's kind of burning rubber tires that get thrown over neck. So this is what she's doing. She's throwing wreaths of tar over the necks of the Spanish soldiers.
夜以继日地不懈工作，试图修复这些缺口。基瑙就是那个成为这项修复工作象征的女性。她从不停歇，绝对是不知疲倦。在随后的几年甚至几十年里，关于她的故事变得越来越不可思议。据说她基本上发明了“项链”刑。你还记得南非的“项链”刑吗？就是把燃烧的橡胶轮胎套在脖子上。所以这就是她所做的。她把焦油花环套在西班牙士兵的脖子上。
This is her signature. Her signature way of killing them. By the 17th century, you're getting prints showing her as a full-blown warrior. She's holding a pike. She has a sword. She has a pistol. So actually, the comparison is Joan of Arc, surely. I mean, that's the obvious antecedent, isn't it?
这就是她的标志。她杀敌的标志性方式。到了17世纪，你看到的版画中，她已经全副武装，成了一名真正的女战士。她拿着长矛，佩着剑，还带着手枪。所以实际上，这很容易让人联想到圣女贞德，不是吗？我的意思是，那是最明显的先例，对吧？
Kind of, except that Quenau is actually, she's not a maid. So she's a middle-agedaged woman she's kind of 40 and there's a there's a painting of her in the reichs museum where she's painted without any kind of hint of idealization she's the you know she's the kind of woman you would see you know in a in a shop or whatever but she's she's got all her weapons and i think it's the it's the contrast between the fact she she looks like an absolutely conventional, ordinary, middle-aged woman. And the fact that she's kind of bristling with pistols and all kinds of things. And it has this inscription, see here a woman called Quenao Brave is a man who in that time gallantly fought the Spanish tyrant.
差不多，除了基瑙实际上她不是一个纯洁的少女。她是一个中年妇女，大概40岁左右。在国家博物馆里有一幅关于她的画，画中对她没有任何美化。她就是那种你在商店或其他地方能见到的普通女性，但她身上挂满了武器。我认为最奇妙的就是这种对比：她看起来完全是一个传统、普通的中年妇女，但她却全副武装，插满了手枪和各种武器。画上还有这样一行碑文：“看啊，这位名叫基瑙的勇敢女子，正是一位在那个时代英勇抗击西班牙暴君的英雄。”
So this is hurrah. And by the 19th century the stories are being told that she's leading a band of 300 female warriors so again a kind of classical echo perhaps of the spartans at thermopylae and there are other stories too of women defying the spaniards and basically the maid of holland is reminding the dutch of this tradition of heroic women and it's reflective of the fact that women as well as men are valorized, are seen as being heroic by the people who commemorate the glory days of the revolt against the Spanish. But I think there is something much more interesting going on as well.
所以这真是太棒了。到了19世纪，甚至有传说称她领导着一支由300名女战士组成的队伍——这又让人联想到了温泉关战役中斯巴达人的古典回响。还有其他关于女性蔑视西班牙人的故事。基本上，“荷兰少女”一直在提醒荷兰人这种女性英雄主义的传统，这反映出在那些纪念反抗西班牙光荣岁月的人眼中，女性和男性一样受到颂扬，被视为英雄。但我认为，还有一些更有趣的事情正在发生。
Okay. So the idea that, you know, of warrior maidens i mean you mentioned joan of arc i mean this is a kind of tradition it's an unusual tradition but it's not an unheard of tradition yeah but i think there is something about the maid of holland that is absolutely distinctive completely distinctive and so interesting about the character of the dutch republic and of its civilization in the golden age and i think we should take a break here and then when i come back we will when you come back no when we come back i'm coming back too yeah sorry did i say did i say just say me i said when i come back okay well i'm i'm so in the zone dominic
好的。所以，关于女战士的这种想法——我的意思是，你提到了圣女贞德——这算是一种传统，虽然是一种不寻常的传统，但也不是闻所未闻的传统。对，但我认为“荷兰少女”身上有一种绝对独特、完全独特的东西，这对于了解荷兰共和国及其黄金时代的文明特征非常有趣。我想我们应该在这里休息一下，等我回来之后，当我们回来时——不，当我们回来时，我也要回来——对不起，我刚才是不是说成了“自我回来”？我说的是“自我回来”好，好吧，我真是太投入了，多米尼克，
that i'm afraid i blanked you out when we come back uh we will explore what it is that makes the figure of the maid of holl Holland so culturally distinctive. Totally good. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works.
以至于我恐怕把你给忽略了。等我们回来时，我们将探讨究竟是什么让“荷兰少女”这一形象在文化上如此独特。太好了。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐余音》。这里有你每周必看的娱乐新闻、评论以及八卦爆料。在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐业的神秘面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。
We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Welcome back to The Rest Is History. Contrary to predictions before the interval, I have returned. I am still here.
我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想收听无广告音频、加更节目并优先购买现场门票，请访问 the rest is entertainment.com。网址是 the rest is entertainment.com。网址是 the rest is entertainment.com。欢迎回到《历史余音》。与中场休息前的预测相反，我又回来了。我还在这里。
I am listening to Tom's wonderful discourse about the Maid of Holland. So Tom, there's been an interesting sort of contradiction in the first half, because you said you were going to be talking about housework, but actually you're talking about pistol work. Yes, I have been talking about pistols and guns. And you're absolutely right. Well spotted. So we are now going to start exploring the dimension of housework. So now we're getting to the really interesting bit so the problem with podcasts of course is that you if you want to talk about visual things there has to be very detailed descriptions but you defy that so i'm going to defy that so i want to talk about um it's an allegory on the deceitfulness of spain and the
我刚才一直在听汤姆关于“荷兰少女”的精彩演讲。所以汤姆，上半场出现了一个有趣的矛盾，因为你之前说你要谈论家务劳动，但实际上你谈论的是枪战。是的，我一直在谈论手枪和枪支。你完全说得对，观察得很敏锐。所以我们现在要开始探讨家务劳动的维度了。现在我们要进入真正有趣的部分了。所以播客的问题在于，如果你想谈论视觉方面的东西，就必须有非常详细的描述，但你打破了这种限制，所以我也要打破这种限制。我想谈谈……这是一个关于西班牙的虚伪以及荷兰共和国的自由与繁荣的寓言，这幅图像印在1615年发行的一份小册子上。我正在实时查阅，这太令人兴奋了。
liberty and prosperity of the dutch republic which was an image on a pamphlet that was issued in 1615 i'm looking it up live this is very exciting. So what you get... I see it, yeah. You get the Maid of Holland. There she is. She's sat in her walled and fertile and prosperous garden. Over her are the arms of the various provinces of the Dutch Republic and of the House of Orange, which will give in due course a king in the form of William III to Britain. There are two Dutch men who are busy tending the garden, making all the tulips and so on grow. And at the gate, you have a Dutch lion, the emblem of Holland, guarding the gate. And outside it,
所以你看到的是……我看到了，是的。你看到了“荷兰少女”。她就坐在那里。她坐在她那有围墙、肥沃且繁荣的花园里。在她头顶上方的是荷兰共和国各省以及奥兰治家族的纹章——奥兰治家族后来以威廉三世的形式为英国贡献了一位国王。有两个荷兰男人正忙着照料花园，让所有的郁金香等等茁壮成长。在门口，有一只荷兰狮子，也就是荷兰的象征，守卫着大门。在门外，
you have the Spanish army and you have a hostile leopard. Yes. And the inscription, see the leopard's nature that is not to be trusted. So the leopard is emblematic. Spain. Spain and potpourri and everything bad. But there's also another note, which is, note the wisdom of renowned Dutch housekeeping. Oh, yes. And so that is the two men. I don't know how to pronounce that. Huishoven or something like that, is it?
有西班牙军队，还有一只充满敌意的豹子。是的。上面的铭文是：“看这豹子的本性，是不可信赖的。”所以豹子具有象征意义。象征着西班牙、天主教以及所有不好的东西。但这里还有另一个注解，那就是：“注意著名的荷兰家政的智慧。”哦，是的。所以那两个人……我不知道该怎么发音。胡伊斯霍文（Huishoven）还是别的什么，对吧？
What a splendid image that is. So the garden is incredibly neat and sort of domesticated, isn't it? And if you think of Amsterdam or Leiden or any of the kind of the great cities of the Dutch Republic, it's that kind of, it's that order. It's that neatness. Yeah. And that is what is being symbolically represented interestingly um well you can't go wrong with a pyramid so note the wisdom of renowned dutch
这画面真是太棒了。所以这个花园极其整洁，带有一种居家般的温馨，对吧？如果你想想阿姆斯特丹、莱顿或荷兰共和国的任何伟大城市，那种感觉就是这种秩序感。就是这种整洁感。是的。而这正是以象征方式被表现出来的内容，有趣的是……嗯，金字塔是永远不会出错的，所以“注意著名的荷兰家政的智慧”。
housekeeping what does housekeeping mean well there are various levels so there is the literal the making of of houses of gardens of cities because you know the netherlands is redeemed from mud it was all kind of mud and bog and water yeah and so you know the walls of the gardens are the basically the dikes that keep the sea at bay but there's also of course the sense of housekeeping that stereotypically women do and again it's it's about mud. It's about keeping the filth at bay. And it's the way in which, for the Dutch, the house and the cleanliness of the house becomes emblematic of what their republic is all about. So Simon Sharma, in The Embarrassment of Riches, he quotes from a household manual that's called the Experienced and Knowledgeable Dutch Householder. And it overtly compares the weekly kind of routine
家政是什么意思？嗯，这里有不同的层面。字面意思就是建造房屋、花园和城市，因为你知道，荷兰是从泥泞中夺回的土地，那里曾经全是泥浆、沼泽和水。因此，花园的围墙基本上就是抵御大海的堤坝。但当然，它也包含了传统上女性所从事的家政的含义。同样，这也关乎泥泞。这关乎将污秽阻挡在外。对荷兰人来说，房屋以及房屋的清洁程度成为了他们的共和国一切精神的象征。因此，西蒙·沙玛在《财富的尴尬》中引用了一本名为《经验丰富且知识渊博的荷兰家主》的家政手册。它公开将每周的家务劳动的例行程序
of housekeeping to the rituals that you might get in a church. So it has a sacral quality, Dominic. So to quote Sharma, the steps in front of the house, the path leading to the house, if any, and the front hall were all to be washed every weekday early in the morning. On Wednesdays, the entire house was to be gone over. Monday and Tuesday afternoons were devoted to dusting and polishing reception rooms and bedrooms. Thursdays were scrubbing and scouring days, and Fridays were assigned to the unenviable job of cleaning the kitchen and cellar. Obviously, you also have to do the laundry. You have to keep the dishes washed. You have to sweep the cobwebs, you have to scrub the steps, but not just the steps, you also have to scrub the paving stones that extend beyond the
与你在教堂里进行的仪式相提并论。所以它具有一种神圣的特质，多米尼克。借用沙玛的话：“房子前面的台阶、通往房子的道路（如果有的话）以及前厅，都必须在每个工作日的清晨清洗。周三，整个房子都要彻底清扫一遍。周一和周二的下午专门用于给会客室和卧室除尘和抛光。周四是擦洗日，周五则分配给清洗厨房和地窖这一吃力不讨好的工作。显然，你还得洗衣服。你得把盘子洗干净，扫掉蜘蛛网，你得擦洗台阶，不仅是台阶，你还得擦洗延伸到台阶之外、房屋之外的铺路石。”这也是职责的一部分。这算是你的某种公民义务，对吧？这是你的公民参与。绝对是你的公民义务。因此，人们只要看一眼就能看出你家是不是邋遢。是的。
steps and beyond the house. So that's also kind of part of the remit. That's your sort of civic duty, right? It's your civic participation. Absolutely your civic duty. And people therefore can tell if you have a slatternly household. Yeah. If, you know, the housewife of the household is sluttish, if she is failing to keep the paving stones in front of the house clean, then the house inside must be dirty. Tom, you said that with the relish of a UKIP MEP. Not at all. It's the relish of a good Dutch 17th century Calvinist. Because the thing is that to us, this actually seems quite normal. The idea of cleanliness, we talked about this in the context of the Royal Navy in the late 18th and 19th century, that they obsessively clean because they have come to realise that this is what keeps germs at bay. But in the 17th century, the idea that you keep not just your house clean, but you keep the streets
如果……你知道的，如果这个家庭的主妇很懒散，如果她没有保持房子前面的铺路石干净，那么屋子里一定也很脏。汤姆，你带着英国独立党（UKIP）欧洲议会议员（MEP）那种沾沾自喜的语气说出这番话。一点也不。这是一个优秀的17th世纪荷兰加尔文主义者的沾沾自喜。因为问题在于，对我们来说，这其实看起来很正常。关于清洁的概念，我们曾在18世纪末和19世纪初英国皇家海军的背景下讨论过这一点，他们强迫性地进行清洁，因为他们已经意识到这是抵御细菌的方法。但在17th世纪，不仅把你的房子保持清洁，还要把街道保持清洁的概念，在访问荷兰共和国的访客看来，简直达到了……某种疯狂的程度。我的意思是，他们觉得这很诡异。所以去过那里的英国访客会觉得非常非常奇怪，在那里你甚至不能吐痰。你知道的，如果你走进一屋子人不脱鞋，女佣就会过来粗暴地对付你，强行脱掉你的鞋子，把你的脚塞进一双拖鞋里。因此，一位英国旅行者将荷兰人描述为“清洁的绝对奴隶”。你知道的，他们认为这非常非常奇特。对荷兰人来说，这是他们与众不同的图腾。所以当他们描绘“荷兰少女”时，有时可能会让她拿着长矛，但同样很有可能让她拿着拖把。
clean seems to visitors to the Dutch Republic, the absolute height of, I mean, kind of insane. I mean, they find it weird. And so English visitors say who go there, they find it very, very peculiar that you can't spit. You know, if you go into a house and you don't take your shoes off, the maid will come and basically kind of rough you up and pull your shoes off by force and put your feet into a pair of slippers. So one English traveler describes the Dutch as perfect slaves to cleanliness. You know, they see it as being very, very peculiar. And for the Dutch, this is a totem of what makes them distinctive. So when they portray the maid of Holland, they may sometimes show her with a spear, but they will also just as probably show her with a mop. a house and the wall around the Dutch Republic. And that idea of keeping something intact, keeping it clean, keeping it ordered, that is, it operates right the way from the individual household, right the way to the whole fabric of laziness. And therefore, the cleanliness of a
一个房子以及荷兰共和国周围的城墙。这种保持事物完好、保持清洁、保持秩序的想法，从个体家庭一直延伸到整个社会的架构。因此，清洁的
house becomes emblematic of the way that the Dutch have been chosen by God for a kind of providential role in his plan. So it's a very kind of Calvinist take. You know, the Calvinism has at its idea that there is an elect, that God chooses who will be redeemed and who won't. And so a house becomes, the clean house becomes the emblem of redemption, basically. And so what's amazing is that the whole Dutch revolt, this whole incredible heroic story, which does, as you pointed out, feature women with cutlasses and pistols and all that kind of stuff. But it's also cast as a great project of housekeeping, of cleaning and sweeping and polishing and scrubbing. And this is operating on all kinds of different dimensions. So it's obviously very, very patriotic. And Dominic, I know that you love a Dutch admiral, don't you?
房屋成为了荷兰人被上帝选中在其计划中扮演天命角色的象征。所以这是一种非常加尔文主义的观点。你知道，加尔文主义的核心思想是存在着“选民”，即上帝选择谁将得到救赎，谁不会。因此，一间干净的房子成为了救赎的象征。所以神奇的是，整个荷兰起义，这个所有不可思议的英雄故事——正如你所指出的，确实包含挥舞弯刀和手枪的女性以及诸如此类的内容——但它也被塑造成了一项伟大的家政工程，关乎清洁、打扫、抛光和擦洗。这在各种不同的维度上发挥着作用。所以它显然非常非常爱国。多米尼克，我知道你喜欢荷兰海军上将，对吧？
You're obsessed with sea battles in the 1650s and 1660s. When we were doing the Battle of Trafalgar, I couldn't keep you off it. So you will remember, you will remember Admiral Martin Tromp. Do you remember him? Big fan of him? Crazy name, crazy guy. Yeah. So he was a famous Dutch Admiral who was very successful at fighting the English.
你对16世纪50年代和60年代的海战着迷不已。当我们做关于特拉法加海战的节目时，我都无法让你把目光移开。所以你会记得，你会记得马丁·特罗普（Martin Tromp）海军上将。你还记得他吗？他的超级粉丝？名字很疯狂，人也很疯狂。是的。他是一位著名的荷兰海军上将，在与英国的战斗中取得了巨大成功。
And he fixed a broom to the bowsprit of his flagship. And the idea was that he would sweep the English off the channel. We know how that worked out. But it's amazing. It's incredible. This is the emblem of- Housework. Martial housework.
他在旗舰的斜桅上固定了一把扫帚。他的意思是，他要把英国人从海峡里“扫”出去。我们知道后来结果如何了。但这太神奇了。难以置信。这就是……家务劳动的象征。军事家务劳动。
Martial housework. Yeah. Nautical housework. I mean, you can't imagine Nelson doing that. No, definitely not. And of course, it'swork. Yeah, nautical housework. I mean, you can't imagine Nelson doing that. No, definitely not. And of course, it's Protestant. Yeah. Because you are sweeping away all the flummery and the ornamentation of Catholic churches
军事家务劳动。是的。航海家务劳动。我的意思是，你无法想象纳尔逊会这样做。不，绝对不会。当然，这也是新教的体现。是的。因为你要扫除天主教教堂里所有的浮华和装饰，
and replacing it with the whitewashed sobriety of a Calvinist church. Yes, I was thinking about the churches. I mean, that's what strikes you when you go into a Calvinist church, right? It's spacious. It's light. It's very clean. It's rigorously, meticulously maintained. There are no sort of dusty cobwebby corners with gilt kind of effigies or something. No. So therefore, clenueless and housework is seen as very Protestant.
并用加尔文主义教堂那粉刷一白的朴素取而代之。是的，我一直在想关于教堂的事情。我的意思是，当你走进一座加尔文主义教堂时，最震撼你的是什么？它很宽敞。很明亮。非常干净。它得到了严格、一丝不苟的维护。里面没有任何满是灰尘、蛛网密布的角落，也没有镀金的塑像之类的东西。没有。因此，洁净和家务劳动被视为非常新教的特点。
And further way in which that is the case is that for Calvinists, to know that you are redeemed, to know that you are one of the elect, you have to look into your soul and kind of cleanse it of every speck of dirt. Right. Yeah. Because if that, if the, if those specks of dirt are starting to accumulate,
而这种体现的另一种方式是，对于加尔文主义者来说，要知道自己得到了救赎，要知道自己是选民之一，你必须审视自己的灵魂，并将其中的每一粒尘埃清洗干净。没错。是的。因为如果那些尘埃开始积聚，
then you have to fear for the future of your immortal soul. And so basically the, you know, the responsible housewife is being cast as the archetype of the good Calvinist. Her scrubbing of a step, her polishing of a candlestick is to be equated to the cleansing of a soul. And so there's a lot of misogyny in Dutch culture in the 17th century, as you know, as there is in all cultures at this time. But cleaning women are invariably portrayed in positive light. Right. of everything that is good. And I think that, so Schama's, you know, the brilliant case that he makes in The Embarrassment of Riches, he says, the struggle between worldliness and homeliness
那么你就必须为自己不朽灵魂的未来感到担忧。因此，基本上，负责任的主妇被塑成了优秀加尔文主义者的原型。她擦洗台阶、擦拭烛台的行为，等同于对灵魂的净化。所以在17th世纪的荷兰文化中有很多厌女情结，如你所知，就像这个时期的所有文化一样。但清洁女工总是被塑造成积极的形象。没错。象征着一切美好事物。我认为，沙玛在《财富的尴尬》中所阐述的精彩观点——他说，世俗性与家庭性之间的斗争，
was but another variation on the classic Dutch counterpoint between materialism and morality. So it's this idea that on the one hand, Dutch culture in the 17th century is precociously materialist. This is where capitalism is being stress tested for the first time. You have merchants who are kind of going out beyond the enclosing wall of the Dutch Republic, out into the world, off to the Indies, whatever, bringing back spices and enabling individual households in say Amsterdam or Leiden or whatever to become rich in a way that individual households had never been rich before. This is the first great bourgeois state, if you want to put it like that. But this obviously spells danger because wealth can be corrupting. But if you clean it,
不过是经典荷兰主题“物质主义与道德”之间另一种变奏。所以这就是这种想法：一方面，17th世纪的荷兰文化过早地表现出物质主义倾向。资本主义在这里第一次经受了压力测试。商人走出荷兰共和国封闭的城墙，走向世界，前往东印度群岛等地，带回香料，使阿姆斯特丹或莱顿等地的普通家庭变得前所未有地富有。如果你愿意这样形容的话，这是第一个伟大的资产阶级国家。但这显然预示着危险，因为财富会具有腐蚀性。但是如果你清洁它，
if you scrub it, then you are keeping that risk at bay. So the idea that you can simultaneously be rich and virtuous requires this idealization of housework. And that's why in Dutch art in this period, famously, it's so domestic. You know, there's a lot of emphasis on domesticity. Still lifes, all that sort of stuff. All that kind of stuff. So you see a lot of paintings of women doing housework, of maids around the laundry chest, lots of pictures of women checking their children's hair for knits. And this is kind of material for art of everything that modernity will be. It's patriotic, domesticated. It's all about privacy, individualism.
如果你擦洗它，你就能把这种风险阻挡在外。因此，“你可以既富有又美德”这种理念需要对家务劳动进行理想化。这就是为什么这一时期的荷兰艺术以极其生活化著称。你知道，这里非常强调家庭生活。静物画，诸如此类。所有这些东西。所以你会看到大量关于女性做家务的画作，洗衣箱周围的女佣，还有很多女性检查孩子头发里是否有虱子的画作。这些都是现代性一切元素的艺术素材。它既爱国又居家。这完全关乎隐私和个人主义。
Yeah, because if you think about it, you know, the English are coming over and they're kind of dirty and smelly and spitting, and they've got their dirty boots. But basically, what the Dutch are doing in the 17th century is what the British will do in the 19th century with their idealization of the home. Very similar ways that the British Empire will be profiting from the riches that are being brought in from the outside world, just as the Dutch do in the 17th century. And likewise, a way of kind of domesticating this is to make a fetish of housework of house cleaning of the feminine character of the house so i think i think it is i hope i've convinced you that that's it you have convinced me i mean the idea that dutch made is still so i googled dutch made um earlier and um so this is like with when you when you had your laptop on the uh when i was watching adam kern's program about r Russia in the 1990s.
是的，因为如果你想想看，英国人过来时又脏又臭，还会随地吐痰，他们还穿着脏靴子。但基本上，荷兰人在17th世纪所做的事情，正是英国人在19th世纪通过对家庭的理想化所要做的事情。这与英国人从外部世界掠夺财富来获利的方式非常相似，正如荷兰人在17th世纪所做的那样。同样，将其本土化的一种方式就是对家务劳动、房屋清洁以及房屋的女性特质顶礼膜拜。所以我想，我希望我已经说服了你……你确实说服了我。我的意思是，关于“荷兰女佣”这个概念，我之前在谷歌上搜索过“荷兰女佣”……
Yeah. So what comes up with Dutch made? I haven't actually... So Dutch made, you'll be pleased to hear, is not a kind of erotic niche. It's a sort of the brand, particularly in America, actually, Tom, images of Dutch made are pretty,
等等，这就像你之前在看亚当·柯蒂斯关于20世纪90年代俄罗斯的节目时，把笔记本电脑放在那里的情况一样。
they recur again and again. So there are Dutch made cigars. There's a company in, where is it? Tennessee. That makes, that makes pies, Dutch made pies.
那么搜索“荷兰女佣”会跳出什么呢？我其实还没……所以，“荷兰女佣”，你可能会高兴听到，并不是某种色情小众词汇。它是一个品牌，特别是在美国，实际上，汤姆，“荷兰女佣”的形象相当……
I mean, I'm giving them free advertising. They make all kinds of, all kinds of fried pies. They say, I don't know. I don't know. I'm not sure about that.
它们一次又一次地出现。所以有“荷兰女佣”雪茄。有一家公司在……在哪儿来着？田纳西州。生产馅饼，“荷兰女佣”馅饼。
You're not sure the Dutch would approve of that. But this idea, the Dutch made is always very primly turned out, the little kind of bonnet. Yeah. Little apron. Clean apron. Yeah, with tulips on it.
我的意思是，我在为他们做免费广告。他们制作各种各样的油炸馅饼。他们说……我不知道。我不知道。我不太确定这一点。
Wearing clogs. And I suppose it does, even now, it captures a kind of, there's a kind of innocence. A neatness. An earnestness to it. Yeah. Which I suppose you could you would say
你不太确定荷兰人会赞成这种做法。但这种想法是，“荷兰女佣”总是打扮得整整齐齐，戴着小小的情调帽。是的。小围裙。干净的围裙。是的，上面印着郁金香。
absolutely captures that spirit of and a healthiness I think yeah healthiness and when would you say the heyday
穿着木屐。我想即使在现在，它也捕捉到了一种……某种纯真。一种整洁。一种真诚。是的。我想你会说，这绝对捕捉到了那种精神，还有一种健康感，我想是的——健康感。
of the Dutch maid ends then or does it never end well I think I think it endures as an emblem of the Dutch Republic and then
那么你认为“荷兰女佣”的鼎盛时期何时结束呢？还是说它从未结束？嗯，我认为它作为荷兰共和国的象征一直延续了下来，然后……
yeah the various iterations of what becomes the Netherlands I think it's still as you say it still has a certain potency. But the Dutch golden age peters out when?
后来成为荷兰的各种迭代形式……我想正如你所说，它至今仍然具有某种影响力。但是荷兰的黄金时代在什么时候开始衰落的？
Late 17th century? Yes. Yeah. Yeah. And I suppose that's- It's Louis XIV. Right. And that's the point at which the art,
17世纪末？是的。对。对。我想那是……路易十四时期。没错。这就是艺术走向衰落的节点，
you know, when we think about Dutch art, we think of early 17th century, don't we, I suppose. Yeah. So it becomes increasingly kind of under the shadow of French militarism and British naval power. But, you know, it blazes a path.
你知道的，当我们想到荷兰艺术时，我们想到的是17世纪早期，对吧？是的。所以它越来越多地笼罩在法国军国主义和英国海上力量的阴影之下。但是，它开辟了一条道路。
And that is absolutely part of what makes the Dutch Republic fascinating. But it's also the fact, you know, I mean, it's so distinctive and brilliant a culture in its own right. And we will definitely come back to the Dutch Republic. I know we've been saying that a lot, but this the first well this dipping of the toe into the subject exactly and if i was to go now tom to amsterdam and to ask for a dutch maid well well we hopefully we may end up going to amsterdam perhaps that would be a brilliant place for a rest is history walking tour wouldn't it yeah we could we could try that out couldn't we yes you can try that out i'll no you you suggested it you suggested it but for now for now uh i think that's enough so that was thanks very much for listening splendid
这绝对是让荷兰共和国引人入胜的一部分原因。但这也是因为，它本身就是一种如此独特而辉煌的文化。我们一定会再次回到荷兰共和国这个话题。我知道我们之前经常这么说，但这只是对这个主题的一次初探。没错，如果我现在去阿姆斯特丹，要求找一个“荷兰女佣”……嗯，希望我们以后有机会去阿姆斯特丹，那或许会成为《历史余音》徒步之旅的绝佳地点，不是吗？是的，我们可以尝试一下，不是吗？是的，你可以尝试一下。我不会……是你建议的，是你建议的。不过现在，现在……我想这就够了。非常感谢大家的收听，太精彩了。
yes that's inspired me to go and hoover my house for some such uh so on that to do it for you i proper proper dutch behavior we'll see you next time bye-bye bye-bye thanks for listening to the rest is history for bonus episodes early access ad-free listening and access to our chat community please sign up at rest is history pod dot com that's rest is history pod dot com To get access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. biz gossip and on our q a we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works we have just launched our members club if you want ad-free listening bonus episodes and early There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
是的，这启发了我去用吸尘器打扫我的房子……诸如此类的事情。为了你去做这件事？这才是真正的荷兰式行为。我们下期再见，拜拜。拜拜。感谢收听《历史余音》。想要收听加更节目、抢先体验、无广告音频以及访问我们的聊天社区，请访问 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。获取访问聊天社区的权限，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。八卦爆料，在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐业的神秘面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想收听无广告音频、加更节目并优先购买……本期节目暂无评论。点击转录文本中的任何句子即可发表评论。